straight to digital no theatrical the
range is kind of zero you know almost
zero to
how much does a film's budget impact
what it'll sell for let's say someone
makes a film for half a million is a
distributor likely to make an offer of
half a million no
um
in fact they don't care what the budget
is they may care from the point of view
of Interest like oh how you know if
they're
um knowing thing about production and
they think oh wow you really this looks
great what did you spend from that
perspective
the distributors in general they want to
all they care about is what it's worth
on the market
and they're going to look at your film
and compare it to other films in their
catalog or in their imagination or
wherever they however they make their
subjective evaluation of your film and
decide okay we think once it goes out
into the world it'll make
um we think we'll make a million dollars
then they might be advancing and they
really have to think it it's going to
make a million dollars in order to
advance half a million dollars
um because there's still gonna be costs
for them to
especially if there's if there's if
they're if they're buying something for
half a million dollars
uh their price you know spending a
couple million dollars to monetize
that thing they can't just you buy
something for half a million dollars you
can't just put it on the
um on transactional VOD and hope to sell
it later
um films don't make that much money when
you do that
um
so it's it's all about what what how
much revenue do we feel like this can
make for us or how many viewers do we
feel like or how many subscribers are we
in a game because of this
this title that's the way you know
Netflix and Hulu and people like that
look at it
um
because at the end of the day
um I've seen half a million dollars
films that look like they were made for
two dollars I've seen half a million
dollars films that look like they were
made for seven million dollars
and so that goes to the talent of the
production company and the filmmaker and
the ability to you know get value from
what they spent
why do we hear that it's bad for
filmmakers to be transparent about their
budget
so with regard to being transparent to a
distributor
um
I think that you know if it's because it
could go you they could go badly two
different ways if I tell a distributor I
made it for half a million dollars their
opinion would be like wow
that was ridiculous like why did you
spend so much money
um and then make them make them afraid
of making an offer because if you're
expecting to make
that much money back they may not feel
like you even even though they're maybe
the best option for you they may feel
conservatively that they're not going to
make that much money for you
um
you know on the flip side
um
if they're if they're wowed by it it
doesn't I don't think it really makes
much difference from them unless they're
the kind of company that
um
is in the business of making films
themselves
and are looking at you as a potential
filmmaker to invest in in the future and
there are very few Distributors actually
most distributors
um don't do that most servers are just
Distributors and so they don't really
you know the budget just doesn't really
matter to them but it might matter to
some some Distributors that um
that actually make movies
well it's interesting because it seems
like with Hollywood we know their budget
and it's out there in the trades whereas
with independent filmmakers we're almost
supposed to hide ours like in a shameful
way
yeah
um I I usually just take the I take the
position of not being hiding it for
shame I just like why does it make any
difference
right like
um unless you
made it for ten thousand dollars and it
looks like half a million and you want
to brag about it and make that kind of
part of your
your pitch that look how great we are we
could make something short but not I
don't find most Hollywood cares about
that
or and I think that story's been played
right we had Robert Rodriguez and a
couple of others that have like wow this
film was made for nothing
um and now people tons of people make
films for nothing every day someone made
a film for almost nothing so it's no
longer really a badge of honor
um it's just another fact
um and not a very sexy one
way or the other I don't think
so I tend to sell people that's just not
they're not going to ask us
so let's not put it out there this way
the way I see it I think it's irrelevant
like look at the quality of the film if
you want it pay the right price for it
but why is it different for Hollywood
why are we okay knowing
the you know this many million was spent
on this film well there again I'm not
depending on the Hollywood film because
there's different there's Studio level
and then there's things that are kind of
made with International sales agents
that pop up to Studio level and so
there's different kinds of Studio films
um I'm not sure we're getting the
accurate budget from
from these people even though they're
public
um sometimes so
um I think there's also
there's been a number of times and you
know the number got out that a
production spent and it was so much that
it had a negative impact on people
viewing the film
um probably would have failed anyway but
there's a few out there that spent 200
million and be you know people were like
wow that that they shouldn't have done
that all right so
um yeah mishtar Johnny Depp Native
American Film played Tonto oh uh Lone
Ranger you know there are a few examples
out there of how it negatively impacted
the the publicity so
um
I think some of the some of the numbers
you see about Hollywood production stuff
out there is guessing really guesswork
and some insulin getting some info
information but that they're not
necessarily publishing every budget for
everybody to see I don't think that's
that's really happening
can you give us the ranges of how much
movies make on various platforms
well I can tell you from kind of a true
Indie perspective right because I work
on a mostly true indie films not made in
Hollywood not made with International
sales agents not made with Kevin Bacon
in it you know those are the films I
mostly work on
um
and I see
um the range of Revenue coming off of
transactional VOD
um which is rental and buying on iTunes
and Amazon and the various cable TV
platforms
um straight to digital no theatrical the
range is kind of zero you know almost
zero to
150 000 about in that range with the
median being much closer to zero and the
outliers
at the 150 range so it's not like the
average is 75.
the average is the media the median is
more like
um 20 000 I'd say 30 000 for most most
films and sorry to interrupt this is for
the life of the term of the contract
correct okay
and most of that Revenue coming in
within the first two years and then just
dropping
um
the next window they go to then of
course is s voter TV sales and the range
there is
not making that deal so there's zero
coming in off of that window
to a couple hundred thousand dollars
with most films not getting that deal
that's probably the the most likely case
to some films getting 40 to 20 to 60 in
that range
and then avod is a growing uh sorry
advertising video on demand which is to
be in Pluto where they're paying royalty
people are watching
um because uh and watching advertisement
rather than subscribing or paying for it
um those platforms are paying 10 to 15
cents per view
and the revenues on there are
um again kind of zero to 150
000 in that range as well
and growing because it's it's a growing
um part of the business because a lot of
people don't want to pay there's a lot
of people who don't have money to
subscribe to 10 platforms
um let alone one
and don't want to rent movies but watch
a lot of stuff in that in that in that
ecosystem now so it's a growing Growing
Place for films to make money and you
can't skip Those ads correct they're not
skipping that's right that's right and
they come up in weird
awful places right as well it's not the
best view to experience and you said 15
cents per is it per view it's purview
what if they if they watch a decent
amount of the film I think it's if they
watch most of the movie then the royalty
paid out is can be 15 cents per view
um
which is a lot better than what Amazon
Prime went down to which is one cent per
view
um so that's been uh but we don't know
where that's going to go because there
are more there are many more avod
platforms out there lots of Distributors
are creating their own avod platforms
advertising video on demand platforms
um
and um
and uh
you know it just depends the 2B was
bought by Fox
um and the way these things go you just
never know what they're going to do with
the platform do they keep it being a
place where Distributors can put all
their stuff or do they eventually turn
into something else like Netflix at one
point was the place where you watched
all the movies you ever could right like
it had every movie now you go to watch
Netflix content on Netflix
um mostly so
so we'll see is that purview per like IP
address if the same user is watching
things over and over again it can still
generate money yeah I'm not sure about
that I'm I imagine that the system
probably has
safeguards against people creating
algorithms so that they just can just
like play a film over and over again and
make it money right I'm sure that they
have safeguards against that but I don't
know for sure